Hello everybody!
Yes, I have revoked your right to rewind because I forgot to do that.
The last couple of days I've been having my staff help me make my waiting room because I get like after the stream I have work to do and then I keep forgetting to make the waiting room but then I got too EP and I was like I'll be like I'll be like at staff can someone make my waiting room I'm too bed too comfy I'm like bed too comfy someone make waiting room I sleep here is thumbnail and because of that I keep forgetting because like every time when I make the waiting room I turn the rewind off so like it's just a habit so I don't have to worry about turning it off when I start the stream but like today like obviously like that's why I keep forgetting to turn off rewind because my staff has last three days because I would do work and then I'd be like I'm gonna lie in bed and I'm like oh bed comfy me no one could get up at staff someone make waiting room because you can't do it on the phone I don't understand I feel like the mobile YouTube creator app should allow you to make a waiting
room on your phone because my laziness knows no bounds I don't want to get out of my bed waiting room.
I wish I could just do it on my phone.
Uh, like, I don't understand.
We live in 2025.
Why can't I make my waiting room?
On my phone.
Then you will never get up.
Like, someone has, I still didn't get up.
I still didn't get up.
I literally went at steps.
Someone make my waiting room.
Like, it doesn't matter.
I still didn't get up.
I just let my staff make it instead um oh yeah and i saw um today i saw the i saw the fortnite tesla car uh like i got it i don't know what it's called i don't know the actual name you know the one where it's like it shouldn't be a car it doesn't look like a car you know what it's i don't even know what it's called it's like it's like the it's like that tesla card in fortnite what is it called i don't know what it's called i really got my only knowledge of that car is that it's in fortnite the the cyber truck yeah i saw two cyber trucks in real life today i is i felt like it's like spotting the lockness monster i saw i saw two assholes today of us because i'm like it's so ugly like you know like you know okay when you see it in real life it's a lot uglier in person i legitimately i'm sorry if anyone actually owns a cyber truck i am so sorry but it is actually ugly in real life I yeah yeah it is it's like it shouldn't even be a car I'm it's so bulky too it's like it's like really big
for no reason and it just it doesn't need I just doesn't even look aesthetically pleased I don't understand is it supposed to be like for safety like why does it look like that like why I saw it too too I The thing is I don't understand like the yeah,
it looks like it looks like it's at like like 50 polygons or some shit I just don't understand I hear it explodes, right?
Like what are the benefits of having the car shaped like that?
It's futuristic thinking you don't and it's supposed to reflect the future I would assume in the future you want a pretty car It doesn't mean like in the future You just lost all sense of fashion like I'm just saying like you just lost like you just lost like the ability to see what looks good or not I that doesn't make sense to me like You just suddenly lost your like ability to comprehend what looks appealing or not in the future
But no it's actually it's so like you would think it's ugly like you're like oh it might look better in like in person
looks a lot worse it's and it's so bulky for no fucking reason too i feel like there's no like actual like protection benefits to having a car look that ugly anyway today we're gonna play uh a lot a lot more holiday night today this is our silk song waiting room i can't believe it's coming up technically it's coming on less than a week on thursday right yeah it's coming on thursday i'm so excited because i've been having a great time playing holiday i don't think we're completing it today but most likely we'll do one more part next week and then think will be good to go for a silk song so i'm really excited anyway let me boot up silk song or not silk song hollownay let me boot up hollownay right now all right guys among us
you guys like my new skin look at stabby stabby i'm in london not only am i among us i'm from london to Savvy Okay, wait this was it look look at how look at my map Where am I?
This is me looking at my map right now and then also what else was there?
Okay, there was like This this night is pretty fucking sus am I right?
But okay, so this is okay.
I like this part.
Okay, this is how this is how this is oh Yeah, I'm like calling calming in and it's like
All right, oh, thank you, Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
I've seen them around.
I think the blind had the benefit of not being able to see this pathetic excuse of a vehicle.
Oh, yeah, the double jump is a jetpack look.
We're in the future now.
All right, where do we go, guys?
I killed the beetle.
Yeah, this is a pretty sussy mod right here.
Yeah, look.
Okay, I just want to But yeah, so yeah, Today is an Among Us day.
Today is a pretty sussy day.
Zekra, thank you for the Aka Supa!
Thank you, thank you, Ray.
I'm feeling I'm feeling pretty sussed today.
Alright.
Where do we go?
Fog Canyon.
Where the fuck is that?
Deep Nester Fog Canyon?
Both of them sound Equally terrible.
One has the fog.
And then the other one is deep.
So I assume it's very dark.
So both of them sound very terrible equally.
Oh, I can beat the game today.
Okay, how long do I have to play to beat the game today?
Wait, oh my god, there's like...
Wait, do you see my slash?
There's like little mongas in my slashes.
East from King's Pass?
Alright, let me check.
East from King's Pass.
Which way is East?
East is, right.
So, wait, where am I?
Oh, I need to get my compass back.
I forgot to fight the boss so I don't have a compass.
Wait, how am I here?
Oh, yeah, because I restid.
Okay, uh...
Alright, let's grab my compass because I can't see anything.
Uh... And then...
Okay, we gotta do this.
There's nothing else I can do.
There's actually nothing else I can use.
Yeah.
Okay, yeah, that's the...
literally the only thing i can do all right my aura all right east of king station where's that the resting grounds no i don't think the i don't think the thorns is good uh uh stinky uh my sussy aura all right where do we go chat i don't have enough money oh i do have enough money Oh,
I do!
Alright, we go...
Alright, let's go to the station area then.
Okay, I have enough money.
I don't remember exactly how to get there.
Okay, we go...
Where is the closest station?
Oh, it should be this way, I guess.
Is this the way the closest station?
I don't remember.
Alright, we go this way.
We'll go...
We'll go to the top part.
I'm trying to remember how to get to the...
how to get to the area to buy okay wait where is it okay where is it like i'm so lost i if i wasn't perpetually lost all the time i think i could finish oh yeah i'm healing myself i'm injecting don't worry i'm injecting something in me injecting the the opioids inside me right now the the The adrenaline.
Doing my part.
Remember the one.
Alright, let's see.
We go up.
It's okay.
It's adrenaline.
Sorry, adrenaline.
Guys, it's adrenaline.
Don't worry.
It's just adrenaline.
Alright, nope.
Up.
There we go.
It's this way.
Oh shit, I was not paying attention.
Don't worry.
Alright.
This way.
Uh.
Where is...
Wait, where is it?
I don't remember.
Okay, wait.
I need to figure out where the shop is.
The shop is...
Are we going to fungal waste?
Fungal...
Wait, where is...
Is the shop here?
No, right?
Is it this?
No.
Wait, where's the shop?
Where's the shop for the...
Is it this?
Is this the shop?
I'm buying charms.
I want to buy charms.
It's orange?
Oh, here!
Oh, there she is.
Okay, here.
Alright, I see it.
Okay, if I take the station, the stack station...
Oh, wait, I don't even need to take the stack station.
just go from there.
Okay, I'll just go.
Alright.
Alright, I can literally calm.
Beam me up.
Okay, now where am I?
Alright, we go up.
Alright.
The issue right now is just trying to figure out how to...
God, please get out of here.
I'm trying to fucking navigate right now.
Please!
Leave me!
Leave me alone!
I have rights to be here!
I have a passport!
Injecting fluids.
I paid hard-earned money for these fluids.
I'm not an imposter!
Get out!
I have a passport!
I have a visa to be here!
all right looking too sussy all right oh wait i don't need to do this i'm so stupid i can literally just go up i can go up and then it'll take me to the charm
all right oh the double jump is so it's so convenient actually
oh just because i'm from London.
Doesn't mean I'm sus.
Everyone in London stabs people.
Alright, it's this way.
I have the right to hold a knife.
Okay, bro.
True.
I have rights.
Okay.
Okay, go this way.
What the fuck?
Oh my god, these guys are so tanky.
Oh, and they...
Okay, it's a good thing I didn't stay there.
Oh my god, these guys are actually so annoying.
Alright, injecting.
Go and play trauma center.
Playing trauma center real quick.
Oh, these guys are so annoying, though.
Oh, I can't beam yet.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
You'll be fighting a lot of bosses to get steady body from Salubra.
It makes your attacks more consistent.
Let's see position easily.
Who Salubra?
Is she Salubra?
Oh, steady body.
Where and you'll be able to stay firmly when swinging your little nail around.
Wait, why do I have to stay?
Oh, so I don't get ricocheted?
I mean, I'll buy it for now.
I don't know about use it, but I'll just buy it for now.
Wait, why can't I buy this?
I'm not...
What?
Wait, why won't they let me purchase it?
I need...
Wait, what?
Oh.
Oh, I need 18 charms!
Wait, how many do I have?
I can't read.
You guys know that.
1, 2, 3, 4...
Wait, how does this say?
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13.
Okay, we have 13.
Yeah, exactly.
It's the London handshake.
I'm being restricted from my culture.
I'm being judged for my culture.
Okay, where do we go then?
Okay, guys, where do we go?
I need help.
I beat the Beatles.
Oh, I'm 17.
I literally need one.
Okay.
What's the closest charm?
I mean, I feel like if we go to a new area, we'll find a charm.
Dirt mouth, go left.
Wait, left.
Right from King Station.
Okay, which way?
Oh, I could have just bought one.
Oh, wait, you're right.
Wait, you're right.
I could have literally just bought another charm.
Okay, I'm going back.
I mean, I can afford it, technically.
I'll just buy another charm.
See, I can read at a first grade level.
I just want to go in and go out.
No, I just need one.
I still need more?
I just needed one.
Oh, I need five more.
Oh, I'm not giving you more of my money.
Fuck that shit.
Never mind.
I'll find...
What?
How did he...
Oh, they explode.
Okay.
I was gonna say, how the fuck did they explode?
Oh my god, I hate these.
These guys are actually so annoying.
Alright, I have to get used to being in Among Us 2.
A crewmate.
I have to get used to it.
I guess.
Because it's a different hitbox.
Well, it's not a different hitbox, but like, I need to remember where my hitbox is as a crewmate.
Alright, we go.
We go get to the station and then go to...
Okay, do we go to dirt map or the royal area?
Or what the fuck it's called?
Is that it?
Alright, do we go?
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, I didn't even see them.
Wait, what the fuck?
Where the fuck is the exit?
Dirt map or the...
No, it doesn't change the hitbox.
It just fucked with me.
Wait, what?
Oh, the exit's blocked.
Wait, they blocked it.
How the fuck do I get there?
Wait, they blocked the area.
That's not legal.
They're doing construction.
I gotta go around.
I can't believe it.
They didn't notify me that there was... They were doing construction over there.
That's it.
I'm gonna contact my local government.
My taxpayer money is not paying for this.
Alright, I need... I'm just going to go to the other station.
It's tradition to block the path due to construction.
Just like Quebec.
And then they're like... And then the construction workers go on strike.
You can have your path, your road again.
Just like France.
I heard that's like a big issue in France.
Where the construction, there'll be construction.
And then like the workers would just go on strike.
And it happens like every couple of months.
Now you're getting it.
Roads get finished in Quebec.
Alright, we go this way.
That sounds fun.
Okay, we go right.
Which way?
I feel like we already went through everything here.
Like the resting ground, right?
Oh, down in, right?
The king's state.
Oh, there?
Here?
The old stack station?
The other construction area?
Hidden path here?
Nope, not here.
here swim forward oh wait there's a hidden path oh cheeky oh that's so cheeky
i didn't notice that oh i did not hit it in time i know you can like do it so that this is real are you real oh look idea I did I'm so smart Why am I forever idea Forever I have an idea Oops Wait what the fuck how
Okay so apparently I don't have like an idle animation Oh that's my lantern there's no there's no swimming we were not the crewmate was not meant to swim guys we were not meant to swim
in here guys i think red is an imposter he took off his fucking he took off his fucking space while swimming oh it's so that's cute why are you dressing down The imposter is allergic to water.
But he's just...
Just flying.
Fuck you, I don't like that.
He's just chilling there.
And it's like, I don't like that.
I guess you're just gonna have to die.
What's this?
Oh, another journal.
He was just bro.
He was just mining his own business.
He was just a regular guy.
It's a traveler.
It's weird.
What the fuck?
Where did he drop from?
Oh, I can dream now the corpses.
Whoops, too late.
Is it here?
Oh shit.
How the fuck do I get across?
I'm just gonna go down for now.
Oh, like this corpse?
No, not like this corpse.
Oh, I hear somebody.
Below me.
Oh, there he is!
No, but fuck that guy in particular.
Okay, is it here?
There's a little gap here.
Oh, I knew it.
Oh, the cornea.
This is just a cozy place.
I've been mentioning about that wilderness beside here and thought a moment's freak was a little called for.
The night sky, you are out of your near the side of the city, but the entirety is here as ferocious as ever.
All right, I'll buy your map.
Buy your map DLC.
All right, city.
Okay, we gotta go down and then right.
That's right.
Making the nerd richer.
It's like, like, don't bully nerds or they're gonna become knights.
Tech CEOs.
There's nothing here.
So I guess we'll just go this way.
Why is it raining men?
Yeah, he's got an expensive way.
Where are these?
Oh.
Oh, I don't like that.
Okay, so these guys just jump.
He just jumped, but now they did.
Can I go?
Is there anything up here?
Okay, I literally can...
Okay, so they don't...
What I've realized is that they actually don't take any damage.
Like, they don't take...
There's no... What's it called?
Throwback?
You don't have knockback.
Yeah, there's no knockback on them.
I don't like that.
What the fuck?
Where did you come from?
Oh, and now they're gone?
Where the fuck did these guys come from?
from.
Yeah, there's no knockback on these guys.
Oh my god, of course!
Get out.
Lads.
Oh, I don't... Oh, this is bad.
This is actually very bad.
Whoa.
No!
The one shot!
Oh!
Okay, how far am I?
How far?
Okay, it's not that far.
Wait.
Where am I?
Wait, actually, where am I?
Wait, why is my compass gone?
Now where am I?
Wait, how am I- Oh my god!
Okay, it's okay.
I forgot to sit on the chair.
Accident removed it.
And I forgot to...
I forgot to take- get on my chair.
I forgot to bench and do the other stuff.
I keep forgetting the bench.
Down I'll go.
No benches?
Okay, let's just...
Wait, what?
Do I have to kill them?
Oh, okay.
I was like... Jesus.
I need to make sure not to get hit by those guys.
Come on.
Okay.
These guys take two damage, and I don't like that.
All right.
Now I gotta figure out where my body is.
Where's my body?
Oh shit.
Okay, it's on this side.
Yeah.
There we go.
Become one with me.
Fuck you!
Oh, that's not instant kill.
Okay, there is, like, slight knockback.
That's good to know.
Alright.
Where do I have to go?
Let's go far right so I can get the bench.
It's just not that obvious.
I want to make sure I'm full HP.
There has to be, like, a charm somewhere.
need just five more charms.
Technically, I can get two and just buy three charms from her.
I could try and buy cheaper.
Okay, wait.
Actually, I'm going to go to the bench.
I'm going to go to the bench first.
Maybe I'll find a vent to get to the bench.
You have a lot of money, so I can technically just pay to win.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
It's okay.
Oh, he got the...
I said it'd be like, it's okay.
He can't make it.
He's too short.
I forgot.
He can jump guys
He's just slowly getting into my aura too, which helps It was not I was gonna be like ha ha I have the high ground you can't reach me there And then he like jumped and I was like oh, oh, yeah, you could do that
My aura
Jesus Oh my god.
Alright, nice.
I just want to make sure I'm consistently full HP.
Oh, these guys are so annoying!
Alright.
The fact that they just follow you, instead of like, going in a pattern, too.
Get my bench.
Oh, is that a bench?
Ooh, this is a fancy bench.
A fancy bench for a fancy crewmate.
Hello?
Who's here?
How did you find me?
Down here, where the world ends.
Yes, I know why you're here.
You came to learn a nail art from the legendary nail master, Oro.
It is a lot of great nail sage that I must pass down my teaching to those who are worthy.
law forbids me from extracting a exacting a payment for my time you truly wish to train under me prove it with geo they're in the master's nail art sure surely this is not a scam right
who's that guy
hold the car oh i get a charge it's like who's that guy that's trading over him that's not me That's John Hollenight.
We banished him.
All right, cons truly sublime on dashing to perform the dashed lies.
Hell a summit.
I must say, you are an excellent pupil.
Your skill with a nail and your thirst to become stronger.
You remind me of my brothers.
I've taught you all I can.
into the world, Traveler, and leave me to my solitude.
Alright, goodbye.
Sorry about my aura.
How do I do it?
Let's do this.
Wait, what?
How do I...
How does this attack work?
Oh, charge and dash... Oh, so when I do this, this is attacking?
Is that it?
Oh.
I'm out.
Wait, how do...
Charge, dash, let go.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I got it.
How come I didn't let me do it before?
Oh, because I didn't let go.
Okay, I had to time it correctly.
Okay.
I get it.
I just gotta time it correctly.
Hello?
Who's this guy?
Dream, dream, dream, dream.
Stronger, brothers.
So you...
It looks like you have a fire cloud following around.
Simple-minded.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Dream!
Oh, okay.
That's it.
Enough dreaming.
Do you get a secret?
Keep hitting it?
Okay.
Did I dream it?
like normal hit it.
Surely something will happen, right?
Oh.
Hey, guys.
Oh!
Okay.
Okay, I knew it.
That's okay.
Wait.
Wait, that's okay.
Oh, shit!
But I could literally just see you.
You're too thick!
Ha, ha, ha!
I'm gonna check some more.
What was that medicine that Dr. House uses all the time?
It's not lupus.
Oh, hey.
Where's those?
Oh.
Vicodin?
Yeah, I'm checking if I could get it on me.
Alright, let's see.
Oh, gosh.
It's a bench.
It's never lupus, guys.
Alright, we go this way.
I need to practice this move.
I feel like...
This move is hard to use.
There's two of them!
Ha ha ha!
Oh, wait, how did you get here?
Oh my god, he really wants to kill me.
How do I...
Oh my gosh, I'm so bad with this move.
Like, oh!
Nah, I'm not gonna use it.
I, like, I think it's a strong move, but I'm just so bad at using it.
Can you actually...
miss the charm?
Was it back there?
Or is it back here?
Where's the charm?
Ground?
The floor?
There's a breakable floor?
Oh, there it is.
Yeah.
Oops.
Mike, thank you for five.
Give the ships.
Thank you.
That's it.
There's nothing else.
Oh, here.
God, these guys are so annoying.
Okay, at the moment, the current most annoying enemy is this guy.
Oh.
Spoiler break.
Well, I hear a grub.
Okay, where the fuck did you guys come from?
No, I gotta kill this guy.
He cannot live.
That's fine.
I'll tank all of this.
I'm okay.
I'm okay with tanking it, y'all.
Currently the most annoying enemy at so far.
Get out of here.
Alright, there is a breakable down.
Oh, it's a rocket!
Oh, fuck!
I didn't realize.
There's so many spikes!
Oh my god, I'm landing in all the spikes I'm actually landing on all of it I can't I can't
Everything is just spikes I'm literally just dying the spikes My one weakness Okay, we'll just Oh wait, I should have need this
I gave up.
He won.
Okay.
He's gonna attack this guy, though, just in case.
He won.
He knew.
Oh, my God.
I've got to get you out of here.
Terrain.
The final boss.
Wait.
What's this?
Oh, it's another round today.
nice i still don't know what this does where's my fucking soul
oh my god where's my soul actually where is it where is my soul why am i here where did my soul go
where did he go he left okay what i got i'm gonna go grab some more soul quick he actually just left he's like i'm done with you i i can't i don't know how i'll get back to the other side let
me just grab this guy real quick no get back here get back here get back in my body oh no oh no oh no no no no
I can't I can't deal with the spikes It's actually like the worst The worst enemy in this game Never mind Never mind the bugs are the second worst The spikes are number one Spikes are number one The hardest boss I've ever faced And it's these guys Truly the hardest like go up they shoot up now all right all right let me try this again yeah oh my god thank God thank God he's on the other side I don't have to get near him anymore thank God I'm freed and that's the grub how did he get here he just Wait,
did I not kill him?
Wait, there's two?
Wait, how come...
How did there...
How is there two now?
Did they multiply?
I don't know what to do.
He's so scary.
I don't...
Oh, go back.
Why?
I freed him.
Is there a breakable floor that I'm missing?
Here?
Through the right of the spikes.
Oh, he...
Oh, I see it.
Where am I?
Oh.
Okay.
Oh my god, this is like a whole maze.
Natural maze right here.
Okay, money.
Is that it?
Oh, this way.
Okay, so there's something...
Okay, nice, I knew it.
Okay, never mind.
It does nothing.
I was like, I knew it.
Never mind.
It's nothing.
Is there anything here?
Just got baited?
There's like so many holes, but there's nothing in these holes.
Oh, I need to try them to read that.
Okay, I was gonna say, like, why is there nothing here?
Go down, I'll go.
Holy shit, this is a long-ass tunnel.
Can I go down again?
Oh, there's another little hole here.
Anything?
No, that's just bait.
Okay.
It's just all bait.
That's all right.
It's all right.
I've been baited so many times.
It's okay, I'm used to it now.
Uh-oh.
That's a lot of money.
It feels like a trap somehow.
Hmm.
I don't think...
It just feels a little too easy how there's just money there lying in this giant hole.
Wait, that's it?
Wait, that's it.
Oh.
It could just be that easy?
Yeah, it feels pretty sus.
Wait, it can actually...
Life can just be that easy?
No.
That can't be.
Life shouldn't be easy.
I can just get a hand up just like that.
No traps.
No bosses.
No flanks.
No ambush.
What is this building?
I know, 420 Geo.
Besides the three deaths, it took to get it.
Alright.
How do we go this way?
You mean I don't need to work for my money?
I can just have it hand out to me?
Oh my god.
I get to be a Nepo baby.
Let's go.
Wait, what's over here, though?
I never go in this side before.
Okay, nothing here.
God, I hate this guy so much.
Oh, and of course I missed.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
I didn't think that would hit me.
I'll just stay here.
Nah.
my aura.
Okay, not now, though.
God damn it.
Okay, come to my aura.
Okay, I'm just getting hit by all of it.
By all the misses.
I'm at.
That's right.
Oh my god, wait, I didn't get hit by that.
Nice.
Alright.
So nice Okay, I sort of don't like the aura talisman Only because sometimes I can't see the missiles Because it's literally the same It's almost the same color
So anybody gives extra hits on those guys plus bosses Oh boy, I like that Okay, maybe I'll swap it then I'll swap it Because I'm getting annoyed I'm getting annoyed because like They're both orange So it's, they're both like blending in
Okay, let's get first before...
All right.
But it's funny!
I can't see!
It can be funny, but I'm blind right now.
All right, quick slash.
What's that?
Uh, slash, oh.
Is it funny when I'm blind?
That's a surprise for a bit.
Comedy is suffering.
Doki.
Just like how beauty is pain.
Alright, where am I?
I'm here.
Alright, let me... I'll swap then.
I'll swap just to...
I'm gonna swap then.
Jesus Christ, there's three of them.
Alright, get over here.
Okay, I guess not.
I'm going to swap the charms.
I'm going to swap this for...
What was it, SETI?
Yeah, no.
These guys are very annoying.
At least I can heal, though.
At least it gave me 30 for a hit, which is nice.
You can't even pogo it, too.
That's the worst part.
Alright.
That gives you a regenerating health.
Oh, I...
I like that.
I like regenerating health.
What the fuck?
Okay.
I got your nose.
Alright, let's see.
We go left.
Oh, so that's where they come from.
Okay, I see.
So I was, like, wondering how the little guys kept spawning in.
Here we go up, then.
This wait there's like a darkness over there what is that can i even can i get through it no i can't i'm not one with the darkness yet i'm not riku
jesus christ oh my god they got a gang on me like i felt like i got a hit
yeah yeah I assume that I need a specific upgrade for that where am I oh guess I won't know all right okay so I did not see this did lactite
oh my god I got hit by all of them oh wait I hear a grub I hear a little guy okay I assume it's It's definitely not...
Wait, maybe?
Oh, I knew it.
Oh, fucking curse.
Oh, my God!
I'm fucking...
Okay, I'm just gonna free you first.
Oh, my God!
Just hit me!
Just hit every fucking shot on me.
Okay.
I knew there was a grub there.
I'm just gonna heal up.
What else is here?
Okay, I think I can pogo this?
Like, the small guys are easier to pogo.
But the big boys, the big boys are a little frustrating.
The small guys, like, is easier.
The big guy is just a little too big.
He's, like, too tanky for the pogo.
What hit me?
What hit me from the...
God just fucking threw a rock at me?
Where did that come from?
There.
Did he?
Oh, Mimi.
It did not seem like he shot me earlier.
Maybe I should have been shooting up.
Gamers usually can't look up.
I don't know where to go.
I'll go left first.
Oh, wait.
Left is...
Oh, left is just...
Okay.
Left is just this.
Wait, how did I not get there before?
I said I jumped here.
Yeah, the difficulty spike is crazy.
Ever since they added spikes, it's all downhill for me.
Alright, this way.
Oh, it's her.
Okay, I'm not going there.
Yeah, I was gonna say...
I feel like I got I gotta fight Silk Song.
Jane Silk Song soon.
Let me go.
Yeah, I'm gonna go to the bench.
I was like, oh yeah.
No, I'm most likely gonna fight her if she's trying to lead me somewhere.
This is this.
Okay, I knew it.
Oh, no, no, no, Jerno.
Can I slash him?
The slash trapped.
That's it?
Came all the way here for you to just say that.
Like, if you're gonna die, die at least with more of an essay.
Alright, we got the bench.
So that means it's time to fight Adidas.
Alright, six song time.
I did say it was a six song waiting room.
Make it worthwhile to read your story.
Alright, let me take a hydrate real quick.
It took me, it only took me an hour to read.
this fucking map.
Quick slash is good.
I don't know how to use quick slash effectively.
I feel like I'm really bad with it.
So you pursue the deeper truth.
So stupid.
I look so stupid here.
Oh, quick slash is the charm.
So you pursue the deeper truth.
This isn't one week.
one the weak could bear.
Prove yourself ready to face it.
I'll not hold back.
My needle is lethal.
Now I feel no sadness in the weakling's demise.
Because I don't know if I could first try this.
I feel like today's made me not my day.
Show me you can accept this kingdom's past and claim responsibility for its future.
Oh,
I forgot all her moves, by the way.
I don't remember any of her moves.
Okay.
Give me a sec.
I'm trying to remember what your moves are.
Okay.
Oh my god.
Yeah, I'm not first trying her.
I don't remember how she moves at all.
I think it's a it's a wait what what what is that wait can I go past that do something I was so confused I was like what are those moves okay she lays okay Okay, now I know.
Sorry, I was enamored by her beauty.
Oh, it's fine.
We don't need those charms.
I can slash them?
Oh, okay.
Oh hey, there's me.
Ow!
What the fuck?
I keep forgetting that I hurt myself.
Oh, she can parry.
Okay.
She's a lot faster.
No, she's 100% lot faster than before.
Adidas!
Alright.
We gotta focus.
Adidas!
She's so much faster.
Can I heal?
Nope.
That answers my questions.
Can I hear the air?
Yeah.
Oh, that's bullshit!
Oh, that's so bullshit!
Cheater!
All right.
Oh.
Oh, I have to hit the spike!
Okay, I thought I could hit the...
I thought I could hit the...
What was it?
Shaw!
Oh shit!
This truly is a hard-haired silkside.
Spikes, my worst enemies!
Yeah, I thought I could just hit the strands.
I was like, why isn't my...
Why isn't my knife cutting the rope?
It's made of silk.
It should be the most easy.
easily cut up a sting.
Uh, yeah, I'm not healing.
Oh my god, I hurt myself.
I'm not healing because I keep forgetting like, I don't know when I can heal because of her range.
Her range is that messes with me sometimes.
Like...
Oh my god!
I'm not playing well.
Today's not my day.
I need us.
Are you serious?
That was such a big.
Okay.
Don't get rage baited.
It's because of Among Us.
You gotta be Jane Silk Song.
If you wanna beat it.
Maybe you're right.
to kill her i have to beat her oh shit i thought she was dead dead i didn't feel it true wait true all right in order you're right wait no you're right guys in order to beat her i must wait what the fuck oh wait in order to beat her i must or how do i do it there we go I must be here.
Only the...
I must kill myself.
Today's my birthday.
Can I get a happy birthday?
Of course, Rell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Rell.
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
Silk saw versus silk saw.
Oh my god.
I'm already feeling it.
I'm feeling it!
I am you!
Alright, I'm locking in.
Oh, Jesus.
Sometimes, like, that messes me up, too.
Adidas!
Okay.
What?
Okay, that's bullshit.
That's bullshit!
That's it!
Okay, that gives me one heal.
Adidas!
Alright.
What?!
Okay, that's bullshit!
Hey golly!
Okay, I knew you saw- I know y'all came because I am!
you really okay that was bullshit that was so bullshit she she did some bullshit moves on me there all right let me change my charms wait okay steady rock get rid of compass and you guys for me to put on was it quick slash do I have enough for it?
I need three okay I can get rid of that alright guess who's the fake I just do okay I do more slashes alright
don't worry I will show her I'll show her I'm the real silk song
alright alright I'm I'm back oh my god I knew like because sometimes you know like she does that thing the close move what I don't get oh nice okay I have a feeling she's gonna do that I swear to God if you do Adidas
Oh, Joyce, I swear to God if you do Adidas!
Ew.
But you want more Adidas?
Maybe spike moves.
Really?
She does another one?
Back to back?
Oh, my God.
But she does the back to back Adidas.
Yeah.
I want to make sure like I can like fucking fight here.
Oh, that's bullshit.
Right.
Okay.
I want to get rid of the spikes so at least I have space.
I just did spring cleaning!
Okay, heal.
Okay.
Okay, there you go.
Yes!
I told you!
I am so sad!
That's right!
I'm you, but smaller and better.
Sometimes people, they get small.
It's not the size.
It's how you use it.
It's so strong.
And I'll have you know.
I am above average.
So strong.
You could do it if you had the will.
But could you raise your nail once knowing its tragic conception and knowing yourself?
calling us head onward burn that mark upon your shell and claim yourself as king you mean claim ourselves as queen only yeah only the size of the heart matters don't get unironically was the among us debuff but it's so silly the among us mod is so good for the safer chat thank you thank you but i get to be silly
marked by hollowness shall recognize the new ruler the kingdom gates will be open it's not good
silly doesn't win wait am i am i supposed to oh i was supposed to leave i was like the building is collapsing should i stay oh wait i might die here
am i alive oh i'm alive yay i did it all technically all me if you think about it because she's me if you think about it it's all of me because she's me I did it.
I saved myself.
I never punished.
Alright, nice.
I did it.
Alright, let's go.
Alright, now I can put this and that.
What was my other one?
Was it?
Oh, it's a geo.
and then the steady one where the fuck is the steady a steady body there it is all right where do we go after that where do we go after that
guys left and up oh the the very up ow
the electrical you're right wait do i gotta fix the lights guys real quick
oh my god every time okay up up has a charm i might as well grab the charm right
yeah i'll get rid of him but don't he wasn't doing anything he was staring at me menacing me Now there's two of them.
Fucking chorus.
Alright.
Hey, Doki, it's also my birthday, too.
It'll make my year review sing for me.
Of course!
Saj, happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Saj.
Yeah, happy birthday!
I have a great birthday.
What's this?
What is he?
Is this smack that?
But no, smack that.
But, uh, uh, smack that.
Wait, he's not coming down.
How much more do I slap?
Do I slap?
Excuse me, sir.
Oh, my God.
I think he likes it.
You fucking freak it down.
Okay, stop harassing him.
Okay, it's not harassing if he's enjoying it.
He paid for his time.
This is a house call.
Smack that.
Wait, what am I supposed to do?
Yeah, he's laughing.
What am I...
What is the secret?
Is that it?
Is that the secret?
smacking his ass?
Keep going up.
How?
How do I keep going up?
He's fucking blocking the only way.
That's the secret?
No, no.
Keep going.
Whoops.
That's the secret to smack a giant.
That's the dev secret.
It's a little Easter egg.
that devs put in.
You get to slap...
You get to slap a giant bug's ass.
What a great secret.
Oh.
What's over here?
Wait, this is new.
Oh, it's just the HP stuff.
Okay, it's just extra HP.
Wait, that's literally it.
It was literally...
That secret was just literally smacking his ass.
Fucking freak.
Wait, I hear him.
There he is.
More tiny thing.
You climb high.
Seek the knowledge of these lands.
This ashen place is grave a worm.
Once told it came to die, but What is death for that ancient being?
What transformation, methinks?
This failed kingdom, this product of the being spawned from that event.
Wait, that's it?
Is there anything else?
If you thought about my tale, rest is somewhat disturbed.
But I find that sensation not a... Oh!
Look, see?
See?
He liked it!
He liked it, guys!
I told you he liked it.
all right he's a freak one prefers mine not to be right it's rather unsettling rather invasive oh he did not consent to that i told you i knew that freak i knew he was a freak
okay where do i go that was it Ow!
Oh my god, I'm lost losing all my hidden- oh my god, I lost it all.
Whoop!
I lost it all.
God, so annoying.
These insects are so annoying.
Go back out to the main area?
What's the main area?
Oh!
I didn't figure out where to go for, uh...
Okay, we gotta go up.
Wait, I forgot where to go for the next story, the story boss.
Is the Colosseum a story boss?
Some people are telling me to do the Colosseum.
I'm just gonna see if I can...
God damn it!
He's so relentless!
This fucker is so relentless!
Okay, it's not required for any ending, okay, so we won't have to do it.
We'll do it another time.
I don't want to focus on doing the story stuff.
It's entirely unnecessary to beat that.
Then why the fuck did I find myself?
Wait.
Wait, then why did I come here?
Guys, what do you need to finish the game?
It's because it's cool.
Alright, I heard there's a charm here anyway, so.
I'm gonna go here for the charm.
Okay, but what about the basic ending?
Poor Emma.
Yeah, we have a lot of money.
Alright, as it gives, good bonuses.
Yes, thank you, and super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I want to get close to the basic ending first before we do, like, the extra content.
I'll do the extra content, like, in the future.
I just want to get as close as I can to the basic ending.
Wait, what's this?
Our dream is the mascot.
Oh, it's the mascot.
Oh, okay.
Do I go down?
What is this?
Oh, it's the kingdom's edge.
Okay.
Where the fuck is the charm?
So quiet in here.
whoa what is here ah another war one wants to do is place your mark upon the trial board there's a small fee attached to trial i'm sure a skill to myself will have quite a wealth of you now before you draw your nail i offer one word of quick advice the reward pit just below where others like yourself await your trial i strongly advise using it to rest up before placing your mask.
Oh, and I have no doubt.
I'm a fearsome warrior myself.
Don't go judging me by my size or my current or constraint.
The Colosseum beckons us both.
I'll be back in battle soon.
Make a contribution and you can enter it.
All right.
No.
No one ever won glory by clinging to the geo.
All right.
Goodbye.
We'll come back later.
I don't feel sussy enough for that.
Well, yeah, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
For basic ending, you need to do one boss, two dreamers, and a hollow night.
Wait, but I'm hollow night.
I mean, we kicked out hollow night.
We banished John hollow night from this playthrough.
All right, let's go.
Uh, okay, what do we do?
Wait, I just go far, right?
Um, John Holloway is literally on the cover?
Stop there.
Just having me step over there quickly and bring your Gio with you.
Where's the bench?
Where do I go?
Down?
I'm so confused.
Under?
What the fuck is this?
Hello?
Oh, there's the bench.
Oh, hi!
Hello!
But I want to talk to you.
Hell, when you found it, too, then.
This perfect place.
I'll soon be entering the battle.
Just taking a moment to rest first.
The field could truly challenge me.
I'm hoping this arena presents the sort of weird challenge I'm after.
Alright, how do I get out of here?
I assume I can climb this.
Okay, I'm...
Oh.
Okay, no.
Wait, how do I get out?
Oh, nice.
Okay, there's a hidden wall.
Thank God.
Oh, hey.
Hello there.
This is not outside.
The other way?
Secret up and right Up Oh, here There's another secret Hello What's this?
Oh, now I'm out of here Okay Nice Wait, there was never a charm Guys, you lie Where the fuck is this charm?
I was told that there would be a charm.
Oh, hey.
There's more stones here.
Oh, it's a Coliseum reward.
Go right?
Hello there.
Oh, he a little crazy.
Is that...
Is that bug golem?
What the fuck was that?
I hear him.
Yeah, it's bug golem.
Oh, okay.
I'll just kill him like that.
I'll just use magic.
My precious.
Just send fireball.
Fireball.
Where did he go?
There we go.
Get down there.
Okay, I think he's back here.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my God.
Fuck Golem.
He's so smart.
Oh, my God.
Okay, that's fucked up.
You know, at first I thought it was silly.
But now I'm mad.
Yoink, man.
Wait, that's a key.
Wait, this is not...
This is not a charm.
Just a fucking key!
Alright, what do I do here?
Okay, he's just sleeping.
He's just eepey.
Wait, is there an ending exit here?
Is there an exit this way or no?
Is that it?
That was the fucking quickest tag of my life.
How the fuck do I get out of here?
Oh my god, this was it.
That's everything.
Alright, beat me up, Scotty.
Okay, so it's just literally just the Coliseum shit.
Alright, we'll go do this then.
Alright, let's kill at least one of the aliens.
Why the water?
What's the water secret?
Wait, Ben?
Am I getting one guy?
This one person spammed water secret three times.
Pretending it's like three different people.
So am I getting one guy?
Yeah, I'm like, please do.
That's one.
Yeah, this one guy spammed it three times.
Making me think it's three different people.
And then I saw the name and it was just one guy.
All right, let's go.
Wait, how do I get out of this tunnel?
I'm trying to figure out how to get out of the tunnel.
I think I can buy some charms now.
Oh.
I'll just climb up from this way.
All right.
Down,
out, go.
No fall damage.
All right.
There's something in a while, but it's not really worth getting now.
Yes, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
I guess where do we have to go?
Uh...
Okay, I guess we'll go with Fungal Waste.
You're a queen station to access this guy?
Ancient...
Why Ancient Basin?
Wait, why Ancient Basin instead of Fungal Waste or Deepness?
What's Acid Skit?
Okay, we don't have to worry about tree ending yet.
Which is better?
Okay, we don't have to worry about true ending yet.
Alright, okay, I'll do what...
Let me do one of the alien bugs, and then we'll go to Ancient Basin, or Basin.
You want to grab the acid upgrade?
Okay, I have to?
Okay, I'll go then.
If I have to get the upgrade.
then I'll do it.
If it's, like, a requirement.
Or if it's, like, actually really good.
Uh...
Do I have a stag beetle for it?
I don't know.
Let me...
Keep the rich real quick.
Oh, fuck.
I fucking stupid anti-parkour elevator.
Oh, wait, no.
Down!
Okay.
Oh, I missed the statulation for it.
Oh, technically, you don't have to.
Just rather annoy.
God damn, stupid anti-Parker!
Where's the mirror?
I need to talk to the mirror to have these spikes removed.
Okay, I gotta go this way.
Okay, oh my god, I hate these already so much.
I don't know how to make it go left or right.
I...
You know what?
I'm gonna go to a stack station Just for it I'm gonna do it just for the fact that I need I need upgrades I have so much money right now and I want to spend it I just have too much money on me I gotta spend Spend it It's this way
That's kind of dirt man mouth and uh we'll grab some stuff we'll buy some charms we'll buy some cheap charms how many do we need now we need four right
okay i'll buy this
and then two
all right and then i'll buy the last two charms from the big lady oh and one okay yeah the charm shop has two cheap ones i was thinking that too i was like i'm pretty sure she has two cheap ones so i'll buy two from her
wait where do i have to go Is it Forgotten Station?
Which is faster?
No, because then I have to go around for that.
If I go from Dream and then...
Yeah, I'll go from the...
I'll go from Resting Grounds.
Resting Grounds is faster.
Yeah, I'll go Resting Grounds.
The other is 800.
Oh, fuck it.
It's alright.
Okay.
I think I'll still have enough for the charm thing anyway in the end I forgot the other one was that
expensive where's the hole oh there it is find a hole for the good and then from here I'll just I'll just UFO it I'm area 51ing right now
All right.
Wait, where is...
Oh, there it is.
Okay, I should have enough.
Oh, no.
Yeah, see, I do.
It's cheap.
Yeah, I have two cheap ones.
I can buy.
Okay, one more.
Yay!
All right, nice.
I might as well buy one more charm from her.
I'll buy one more just like in just just because I can all right now now I have a lot of charms and by that now I have one more what can I do with this one charm absolutely nothing
absolutely oh fuck y'all put this just for fun Quick focus is nice.
Yeah, but I just don't have enough space.
I need steady body.
I need to know where I am at.
Quick slash.
That's two, though.
I don't have enough to...
That's three.
Alright.
Let's go to...
Map time.
Uh...
What is the closest?
Oh no, I do have a stack.
station okay where am i all right it's easier for me to go back to the original never mind i can't go back okay how do i get to the closest stack okay it's easier for me to go down all right
oh wait i'm not supposed to be here i can go oh it's too late
But I can just go up from there.
Oh, I can?
I need a healer, so I'm just gonna...
Does that guy okay?
Oh, no, he died.
He exploded.
He can go back up?
How?
Wait.
Oh.
Parkour!
Just be a gamer.
Alright.
This way.
Oh, wait.
There's an egg.
Yay!
Egg.
Guys, I just can't get my swimsuit wet.
That's why I take it off when I swim.
Alright.
Go this way.
Wait.
How do I get it?
Oh, it's this way.
I swear, I've just been lost the entire time.
This place here is just me trying to figure out where I'm at.
We did one boss in like an hour and a half.
Here?
No, it's up here.
Alright, see, now I learned the bench.
Okay, then we have to go to...
Where was it?
To the hidden station?
Where the fuck is up?
Okay, so where do we go?
We're in the ancient...
We're in the ancient basin.
Or whatever the fuck is called.
Queen station.
Sewers for the upgrade?
Or left and dropped down the pit.
Go down?
You were saying for the acid stuff.
Surr upgrade is useless.
Wait.
So I'm not supposed to be here?
Okay.
Acid is unnecessary.
Oh.
Okay.
Then where do I go?
Queen Station?
I already fought Broken Kid.
Isn't that the...
Wait, isn't Broken Kid in the vessel thing?
Guys, I'm so...
Guys, I'm so confused!
Where do I go?
Alright, we're in Queen Station.
My chat is fighting!
Stop fighting!
I'm so lost.
for this area.
Then what do I do here?
I'm fighting more.
What?
That hits me?
Oh my god.
I didn't realize it has like, um, what's it called?
It had, like, it like, fucking hit me from there.
Go towards, I don't have a map.
Go towards the mask.
My fucking map doesn't show me anything.
Oh, here?
I assume it's here.
No, not homing.
It had like...
Wait, then how do I do this?
Ow.
How do I do that?
Oh, sewers.
Right side.
Alright, it has the...
It has another use either is needed here.
The royal...
Oh, it's had to go to...
Go to Hidden Station.
Go...
Okay, two people came super chatted.
Gave me two very different answers.
Two people super chatted back to back.
And they were both very different answers.
I...
Choose...
one.
Follow me.
You need to bet, Toki.
Don't you know how to play among us?
You actually beat a pack of pain in the game before I'll drop an Akasufo when I get paid.
Beat it after I'll drop a Magenta instead.
I'll get paid.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You must choose.
No, PS PS PS I and and Gina both gave me two different answers, but they you for the super chat thank you thank you
the royal waterways has the acid upgrade the ancient basin has another either is needed we ignore us we have no idea thank you okay i'll do the royal waterways how the fuck do i do the royal waterways where is that
your own adventure one super chat tells the truth the other tells lies choose wisely many thank you for the super chat thank you thank you go to the city okay okay we're going to the city
Where's the sewer?
Okay, the Royal Auto is just down.
Is it easier for me to go from King Station to there?
Yeah, fuck it.
Let's just go from here.
You can beat the game.
Oh my god, okay.
Okay, I'm doing a pull.
I can't.
I'm being like tugged from, you know, like in the middle.
and like one chat's talking me to the left the other chat's talking me to I'm making a poll I gave up I Where
Ancient or water I'm talking I'm being tugged left and right right now I have no idea
Alright Here we go It's time to figure it out guys we need to tie the pole all right okay water is currently winning okay all right okay well okay how do i get there all right we go down all right we'll go up we'll go down right now actual 50 i don't know which one even chat doesn't know
all right we go this way i just picked randomly
just pick one
all right i swear to god our stream we would finish this game so much faster if we were not struggling to figure out where to go
oh my god it's too late i'm already at the waterways it's too late we gotta We gotta make progress, Chad.
It's too late.
I wanna make progress.
Okay, it's this way.
It's too late.
That's right.
This is a hard lesson that your vote doesn't matter in the end.
This is a lesson to all.
Your vote never mattered.
I'm already here.
All right.
the right and down right and down oh yeah we got set a bench where's the closest bench okay we'll go to this bench first before we do that bottom right there's a spot you didn't go down all right harsh lesson for all of you your vote never mattered i was just closer i went to wherever i was closer still it's my democratic duty Guys,
thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh.
Alright, right and left.
Oh, you mean.
Oh, wait.
Is it...
Here?
Wait.
Oh, my God.
I can hear them fucking choking.
Here?
Is it this?
Right here?
Guys, is it this?
Is that what I didn't do?
Okay.
Yeah?
Alright, we'll get it.
Oh shit, did I...
You already went the wrong way.
God, I hate these guys so much.
I actually hate these guys so fucking much.
And then when they pretend to be dead too, that's the worst part.
Like, she'll never know.
Don't go there.
It's actually there.
I'm just gonna fly over there because this might be easier.
Oh, shit.
Okay, it's this way.
Lily, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Down with the tote heater for democracy.
Hey, guys, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Okay, this is where I never got...
Okay, so I haven't gotten here.
I won't randomly fly, just in case.
Get this way.
Alright, these bugs are not as annoying after going through whatever the fuck the jumping guys were.
Is this necessary?
I keep going.
Okay, I'm here.
Alright, dash all, oh my god, it's these guys.
Okay, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I just saw it, I was like, no.
I was like, cut my life.
I do not have time for that shit.
Okay, that's fine, actually, that actually works out for me.
I think... No, that's not a grub.
That's like those little flying fuckers.
Wait, what are they doing here?
Wait, what the fuck?
What the fuck was that hitbox?
Oh my god, this is an actual maze.
Oh my god.
This is an actual fucking maze.
I don't even know if I'm going the right way.
I hear something above me.
I hear someone laughing.
Hello?
Oh, hi.
Oh, what a surprise.
It's not often I receive visitors.
It's been so long, ages even.
I just hope my manners haven't left me.
You've no doubt since my affluence, you're right to yes.
I'm renowned upon the upper cast of hallowness.
was once until those creedins cast me up.
Have you met them, my farmer fellows?
That's them outside.
Their bodies shambly around, all mindless and empty.
And I'm still alive to witness their pathetic demise.
Oh, she's petty.
I like her.
I'm just so happy, making me a wonderful thing.
What's that?
Oh, it's shortcut.
Okay, so I have a shortcut now.
You need a one-up grade or the other and you get one you don't need the other for a normal ending pin think of a super chat thank you thank you she's a petty queen i like that that's right embrace the pettiness okay i went the wrong way so i should not be here then where should i be i was like wondering like why the fuck are there royal royal guards here It's like,
you're only for my money now.
Should have hit it better.
Oh, dream, too late.
No dream now.
I always forget to dream now.
Only those who prove they're on in combat may enter the group beyond.
Yeah.
Yeah?
I always forget to dream now.
dream nail.
It's just not in my head.
It's not mentally in there.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many tunnels.
Okay, I clearly can't do that.
Yeah.
This has to be the upgrade thing that I need.
Oh, wait.
There's a trap.
They're pretty weak, though, for a trap.
Yeah, like, my nail is so upgraded now.
I was gonna say.
It's not a very effective trap when our nail is pretty upgraded.
Alright, is there anything in here?
Whoa, where am I?
They're just trying their best.
Oh, is it this?
Yay!
Now I can swim in acid!
Let's go!
Yippee!
Look.
look even though i'm immune to acid it doesn't mean my spacesuit is
i gotta take off my spacesuit whenever i swim in it who is this i thought we banished john holland night what's this oh it's the trap
wings thank you with a super chat thank you thank you you You think, uh, Doki, I tried to collect the super samples and Kaelid and vent before Venom, Collapser, and Eesguard?
Haunt, I feel so complicated.
Thank you for the super chat wings.
Thank you.
All right, here you go.
Oh, wait.
I forgot about the shortcut.
I should go to the shortcut.
Oh, what is the shortcut again?
It was like here, right?
It's like here, and then...
Okay, so...
So what you have to do is beat my land.
Trust me, I'm never right.
Thank you, Golden.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah, I'm like that guy in Rick and Morty that can swim in acid.
He was okay.
He was all right in the end, right?
All right, what's the dream now?
Free!
I'm not like this one, or this one when we had to smize the nails of the city guard.
I'll live here to not live here, too, little girl.
As I did the other.
Oh, my God.
She's fucking, she's an evil bitch.
Holy crap.
Holy fuck, she's evil.
Okay, maybe she's petty, petty.
Dream,
dream, dream, dream, dream.
Bro, hey, I didn't even do anything to you.
Kind of hot.
Let's see.
Alright, now that I got the thing, I can do...
What is it?
station ring ring ring oh my god two hours in we are doing like a little we're like in a filler episode this feels like a filler episode okay fog canyon time
all right we go this way
all right back to fog canyon wait this This is fog canyon, right?
Oh, it is.
Oh yeah, that's why I hated this area.
Wait, I should go back to the bank and get my money back.
Hello.
How much money do I have?
Oh, it's 100.
Never mind.
You can keep it.
I don't really need $100.
Goodbye.
You can keep it.
I'm not that desperate for my 100.
I'll come back later.
Okay, we gotta go...
This way.
Oh shit.
You didn't even super chat, did you?
Thank you.
All right, we go this way.
Yay!
Where am I?
What is this place?
Oh, boy, should I have a map?
Oh, the Queen's Garden is.
What does that mean?
Oh, yeah, I have the Thorn Shit.
That's why they're getting damaged.
I need Basin to fight.
But you guys said that I can just fight.
I need one.
Oh, my God.
She dies and does...
Oh, please!
Stop firing me!
Wait, I need Basin for this area.
Oh my god!
Okay, let me go back.
I swear to God, we are making zero progress.
Oh my god, your body is still there?
I guess I'll go back.
This area is true ending.
Where do I go?
What is a non-optional ending?
Wait.
How do I get to this guy?
I thought I'd go to the fog, yeah, I get to get him.
I don't know what other pathways lead to him.
We're not doing a secret true ending today.
Guys, we don't need to do true endings today.
Okay, pungal waste.
How do I get there?
Oh, I see it.
I see it.
It's like this, right?
Right here?
Okay, there you go.
We figured it out.
But yes, then thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Alright.
Now.
Now, guys, we figured it out.
Sorry, we were just on episode.
So 345 of one piece right now.
Don't worry.
No.
All right.
Surely we're going the right way this time.
Whatever is the most recent suggestion is, I think we should do the opposite.
Nerdy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, shit.
Whoops.
I did not mean to actually hit him.
All right.
gotta go this way yeah we're almost there I think it's like this oh thank god this guy's one shot
and then oh wait he's so alive enough what there you go yeah these guys are easy to kill now I'm so strong I'm a strong boy I'm not going the wrong way but once I could go from the fungal ways not this one yeah
I was like wondering is it not this way stop fighting you guys you guys are having your fucking silver war I'm just trying to figure out where to go I yes you're having like a silver war I'm like would have go fight a boss please oh
my god i'm like i'm gonna fight fight fight all right i'll grab this one for now let's grab these guys just because they're like there anyway jesus christ
okay no oh i fell all the way down okay nice
Nice.
These mushrooms are very annoying.
Okay, we got all of them.
Yay!
Now we have 561.
Oh, I don't like that.
We're back here.
Oh my god, I forgot!
I forgot they do that.
I'm just like, I'm gonna kill you.
I just wanted to kill them just because I can't.
But I forgot they hurt.
Okay, let me go this way.
And then we swim, swim, swim, swim.
Now we're at the infected crossroads.
Wherever, where am I?
Wait, I'm here?
Oh, I think I should have went down.
I'm like, where is this place?
Yeah, I was like, wait a minute.
I'm out here.
Oh, it was just a shortcut.
Yeah, I went the wrong way.
Just gotta make sure I don't.
Ow!
Ow, I hit...
Oh, oh my god!
Am I okay?
I'm okay.
I just, like, hit like, five different explosions.
I think I'm okay.
Okay guys.
Okay, that's good.
I needed this.
A little worry there.
Oh wait, I can swim this.
I don't have to worry.
I literally can just swim all through this.
Are you serious?
Like how the fuck do I get rid of that?
Oh my god.
I don't know why I did that again.
I thought it was further away.
I was like, surely I'm further away now from it, right?
Sorry, I had to test it again.
I just don't touch it.
I was like, but maybe maybe it'll be different.
I just thought it'd be different the second time I do it, guys.
I was like, oh, It'll be different, I swear.
But I can't even pass this.
Toki, there is a jump button.
Why would it be different?
I don't know.
I just thought...
In my head, I was like, oh, maybe this time.
Maybe this time it'll work.
Oh my god, there he is.
Oh my god, finally a map.
Oh, as much...
As Yosemite Mohanus can be here, there's a whole new level of sweetness about these days.
Do you see the dark green for now?
It's quite unsettling.
To be near, I did my best to avoid it.
Fortunately for me, I found another route in.
Though I did end up a little since after weeding through some rashes.
Which is a map?
Yeah, I might as well.
Give me that map.
Oh, there he is.
Okay, I just gotta go down.
Oh, I see the alien.
Wait, I don't have a bench.
Oh, my God.
When was the last bench?
Okay, guys, maybe I can first try him.
Maybe.
Maybe there's hope.
There is a bench there.
Okay, you guys better not be lying.
Surely.
Surely there's a bench, right?
Okay.
It's nice that they have these platforms when I can just...
Oh, I guess they can get one upgrade or the other.
Depends on which upgrade you get.
Ow.
Ow!
What the fuck?
He, like, slapped me into the angelic fish.
Okay.
I guess I might be dying, but...
But I'm gullible enough to believe in you.
Alright.
King's Pass, which is right before Dermot.
I've heard you need to beat that before the first set.
Can people confirm?
I'm just...
Oh, shit!
I thought I was reading chat.
I'm generally curious.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, there he is.
Where's the bench?
There's Quora.
Doesn't this kingdom just abound with surprises?
A building atop an acid lake.
this site, I can't help but feel familiarity.
Something stirs in my mind.
Although I can't tell yet, tell yet, tell what.
I thought it meant less for discovery that led me here, but now there seems something else.
This building beckons me.
Where's the bench?
Oh wow, my chat died.
I can't believe it.
I have a shortcut!
Oh, there's a bench inside.
Oh, okay.
it's inside the hole.
Alright, let's go inside.
Teachers Archives.
Where have Bench yet?
Oh, there it is.
Oh my god, Chad did it not!
Let's go!
Okay, since I don't think I need the compass here, so I'll put that out.
I'll take this out.
And then let's see if I have anything I want to put.
That's two.
Alright.
We'll be able to dash more often.
not in the strike flow i'll do the strike flow from further away since i have two let's see i'm just gonna make sure all right compass is a must during this fight you gotta know where where you are on your on the map you don't understand in this boss but oh okay if i can do that then i'll grab the shaman stone Oh,
wait, shit.
I need that.
Actually, I have.
I'll grab the... Oh, I was gonna say the Soul Eater.
Um, but it doesn't work like that.
Um...
Maybe...
What can I... What should I put on?
Quick Slash or Mark of Pride?
I guess I'll do that.
I'll do... Oh, Quick Slash is better?
I feel that!
Okay.
Mmm...
You want spells?
Okay, then I'll just do...
I'll do range then.
I'm gonna do range.
Oh man, I wonder where am I?
It's like I haven't moved from this fucking map yet.
God, if only I equipped the compass, guys.
I assume it's this way.
I assume it's just down.
Like, you just go straight down.
Which feels...
Oh, there it is.
Oh, it's just a giant jellyfish, isn't it?
Oh, my God, it is.
It's literally just a giant jellyfish.
Oh, this...
Oh, I...
I hate it already.
I hate it.
Oh, I hate this bot.
Oh, yeah, no.
I can't stand still.
Okay, now I know.
But how do I kill him?
What the fuck is wrong with you?
Oh, hey, Quirl.
Oh, Quirl's helping.
Oh.
Oh, nice.
Okay, I just got a...
Okay, I get it.
I literally just...
What the fuck, Quirl?
I thought you were helping me.
Quirl, do your thing.
Just slash him.
I thought you were helping me.
Oh my god, oh my god, okay.
Jesus Christ, no, this guy.
Oh, this guy is annoying, annoying.
The fact that I can't charge anything here, too.
Does he hurt me from...
Okay, no.
Yeah.
Okay.
Just focus on that running away.
Running away!
We're bravely running away!
Yeah, wait.
I literally gotta wait till Quirl does his thing.
Gotta rely on...
It's like a group project.
I gotta hope that my fucking buddy is doing his work in this group project.
Which is so risky.
When your entire group project relies on one person.
Okay.
Just run.
God damn it.
A fucking range for that shit.
Yeah, I gotta wait for him to do his part.
Okay.
Absorb.
Can I expect my boy Coral to help you about Orba farming?
Doki.
Thank you.
He's so cool.
He spent 80% of that fucking fight going Hakim, Hakim.
I just did nothing and then nothing.
That's all he did.
He said his like the catchphrase and then like did nothing.
He's so cool.
It's very... Which way do I go?
Left or right?
VD's or a farming dokey?
all right you couldn't do that without him does it matter all right i'll just go left then
the fact that like this entire route project relies solely on him take full with charged lumiflimes okay
oh wait what's this what the fuck i'm not reading that nerd shit.
This.
Guess I go left?
There was so much stacks.
I was like, this shit does not look like I didn't do anything.
Something glows within this tank.
Something glows within that tank.
Hello, Quiru.
She called to you, eh?
I realized it's no coincidence we arrived.
together though much of my memory is blank this plan I recall within these chambers to teach yourself to store the kingdom's knowledge and at its core she stored herself to save Holiness the teacher willingly became a seal but upon herself she enacted an additional protection though I cannot recall it happening I played a part in that fact she called me here now to reverse that protection all in need of you oh wait that's his mask Oh,
that's him!
Dream!
I think such a small creature will bear this kingdom's fate.
You're not Hesse.
The choice to reform was hers, not mine.
Oh my god, he gave it.
The mask was her all along.
She knows what you would do and seem to welcome it.
Oh, he's so naked now without the mask.
I like him with that mask.
This is weird.
Do I dream her?
Dream!
Yeah, sexy lava lap.
I assume she was a teacher.
For diversity, a seal.
A world forever unchanging.
The seals must break.
Forever.
All right, goodbye.
Welcome to London.
It's a London handshake.
Need a focus.
Don't worry.
I'm pumping a lot of stairwells into me right now.
Yay!
I'm just giving her a welcome back.
Bye!
guys why are people telling me not to go to blue lake and then like several other people were like go to blue lake what is what is wrong with blue lake tomato's life is extinguished and with her with it her seals break don't come stop fighting i've seen your powers up close she too believe you're capable be on your journey then and allow me to rest the time I begin to feel my age.
Alright.
Go to Blue Lake, smile.
There's people that want the other dragoons to suffer, and then there's people who, like, want you guys to not suffer.
I don't even know where the fuck Blue Lake is.
I don't even know where that is, guys.
No, there's nothing at the bottom, right?
Is it a lake that's blue?
I want war.
Pull up my map.
Hmm, I wonder where I am.
Man.
Yeah, I don't think I risked that.
I was like, I don't think that was gonna hit me.
I shouldn't even remember how to get back up.
It's like up top somewhere.
It's like here?
I assume.
I knew I like went up.
Yeah, there you go.
If only I had a compass to tell me where I am.
Oh wait, I have to go back to this bend.
Alright, now I get rid of...
Mark of Pride.
Get my compass back.
my gathering swarm and what is it thor in here
all right all
right we'll have a pull for blue lake because i have no idea what blue lake is
first off i gotta figure out how to get there we're actually doing blue lake
And that chat is filled with apostas and everyone is fighting.
Please release us from this suffering ever since I put on the suit.
The chat has been in shambles.
Thank you for the super chat, Gabriel.
Thank you.
Whoa, wait.
Someone's sleeping.
Who's sleeping?
I Hear me me me me me me me me It's like this side Oh shit, I fucking knew it I was like
All right I knew it.
I could feel it.
I could hear the snores I was like there's so much sleeping above me He's like me me me me me me me me me me me Okay, at least now I'm back.
Uh, Zenya, thank you.
Welcome to tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Mentally prepared myself.
Why?
Someone just, is someone gonna die?
People only say that if someone's gonna die.
Lucky for you.
Not all bug.
Oh my god!
What the fuck?
Lucky for you.
Not all bug lives matters, especially hornets.
I feel like it won't affect me that badly.
PSN Welcome to Tamia Farm Welcome, welcome I want to see blood Fight, fight, fight How could you?
I'm literally killing other bugs What do you mean?
Watch this Okay, alright, I'll prove it to you I'm literally killing other bugs As a fellow bug say you could not say that guys look at this yo do you think this guy's life matters you think he matters not anymore
all right um big blue lake is a big blue lake by the resting ground all right let's go there Wait, no, he's cute.
Alright, here I am.
It looks like Blue Lake has one.
You saw Ramblin' exploding while we gaslight you through the wrong speedrunner strats.
Thanks, Wings!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Alright, if you go to the deep nest to get the other alien mass upgrade, then that unlocks the final boss.
lore and an upgrade.
Okay, we'll grab the last alien mask, and so that will unlock the final boss, and then because we unlocked it, we will do, um, the ancient Basin for the lore and upgrade then.
Alright.
Oh, there's Blue Lake.
I see it.
Alright, time to go to Blue Lake.
Wait.
Yeah.
Alright, we're here.
Alright, guys.
It's time to see why you guys fought about this one particular area.
I'm very curious.
It made chat very divided.
All right, here you go.
What's in this lake?
Oh, hey.
It's him.
Oh, is he gonna drown himself?
Because he's maskless now?
He's showing the world his mask.
Again we meet, my short friend.
Here, at last, I feel at peace.
Twice I've seen this world.
Though my services may have stripped the first experience for me, I'm thankful I could witness this beauty again.
Holiness is a vast and wondrous thing, but with as many wonders as its holds, I've seen none quite so intriguing as you.
Ah, my flattery turns only silent stoxism.
I like that.
Beep, boop, boop, beep.
I like that very much.
Alright, crewmates can only talk in beeps.
Spend a final moment with Krull.
If I just leave and don't sit with him, does he just stay there?
Oh, dream now.
Dream!
To live an age yet remember so little.
Perhaps I should be thankful.
All tragedy erased.
I see only wonders.
Dream, dream, dream, dream, dream.
Dream, dream.
All right, let's sit with him before he, I guess, dies.
Oh, shit.
Who's this guy?
All right.
We're going to watch this live.
Is he not going to get up?
Oh, okay.
I just put on my suit.
I take it off.
Put it on.
All right, come on, guys.
Come on.
Let's go.
Swim with me.
We can go down together.
Girl.
I'll leave and come back the room.
Alright, Quirrel, let's go!
Come on!
Watch up close!
You monster!
What am I doing?
I'm just going on a swim with my bro, Quirrel!
Tokey, please!
The water is so nice!
Alright, is he...
Oh.
He's got...
I find his body floating in the water?
He's a...
Maybe he's still there in the water.
Goodbye, Quirrel.
Oh no, he's gone, gone.
Oh my god.
Goodbye, Quirrel.
We'll miss you.
Adios.
Maybe he's just on vacation, guys.
You don't know that.
There's no body.
if I remember you can save oh well that's too late he could have just left town yeah he was like well time to retire we don't know if he actually died he could have literally retired chat
too late for that we're gonna see him in silk song guys we're gonna see him in silk song retired and went home.
He might as well be dead.
I remember how I get to ancient Bees and whatever it's called.
Put on your water wings, bro.
Everyone is crying and joking.
Like, put on your water wings, Rachel.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You guys are so pessimistic.
You don't know if he's actually dead.
He literally could have like i've done my job and now i'm gonna go retire to hawaii or something loud thank you for the super chat thank you are you crying dragons good thank you for the super chat thank you thank you hidden station
yeah all right we go this way uh wait there's no chair here i guess you see it say that's a bug's life.
Name is Super Chat Patreously.
Thank you.
Also, I read it earlier.
Someone said that that I should do the basin first so that I can so I can complete the Jane Silkson story.
So I'll do that.
Wait, was there?
Oh, there is a bench.
I just missed it.
Whoops.
Where's my bench?
Oh, it's on the other side.
Jesus Christ.
It's not uniformed.
Okay, bugs normally don't live that long anyway.
He lived a very fulfilling life.
He lived way longer than he should.
There's a bug.
There's a fly out there.
There's lots of bug species out there who are born and they literally have like, what is it, five hours to live before they die.
so that crow lived a good life they are born they fuck give birth and then they die so that crow lived a good life oh they don't get knocked back okay I think it's less than that it's like three hours I don't remember I know there's some bugs out there that that's entire existence is literally just hatch out of an egg grow for an hour buck lay eggs then die before they can even see their kids hatch our pure vessel has ascended beyond lies only the refute and regret of its creation we shall enter that place no longer all right is it not here oh it's here knock knock that sounds like a live oh okay let me in I assume I just had to go down.
Where do I go?
This way?
Don't wait for him to...
Ooh.
I'll be careful here.
I want to fall into the depths.
I don't know where to go.
Do I really just go down?
There's like so much shit here.
here maybe
he went back to his wife you don't know that that's a course okay that's nothing
all right nice nothing all right oh money
yay money
jesus like i don't I'm trying to figure out where it's such a maze here in general because I'm like wondering like oh man am I heading the right way oh I literally could just fell all the way down oh hey those my brothers they look like me oh I could have yeah I should just leap of faith it how was I supposed to know I could just assassin treat it wait which one do I go left or right Hello?
Oh, there's ghosts here.
Oh, shit.
There's lots of ghosts here.
Right?
Left is an upgrade you don't have.
Oh, should I go left then?
Oh.
Okay, left is an upgrade.
Yeah, these look like my brothers.
My god.
Whoever my mom is.
And my dad.
They'd be having a good time.
Oh, both are upgrades?
Okay.
I don't have the base thing to upgrade the left.
Oh, I need an upgrade that I don't have.
Oh, okay.
It's basically like...
Um...
It's like basically they're like, you are not successful, so we're just gonna make another one.
Another child.
What the?
What?
What the fuck is that?
Ooh, I don't like that.
Looks like they're trying to grab for my soul.
Here we go this way.
Yay!
Hello.
Hello, brother.
Not my fault you were a failure.
And that mom liked me more.
Maybe if you didn't fail, you wouldn't be dead.
Ow, I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I did not mean that.
I was just joking.
Just some sibling joking going on.
You know, just a casual sibling sibling banter.
Say that again, Toki.
Alright,
nice.
Out of them.
Wait, they don't even give souls.
I'm literally killing a soul.
How do they not give souls if I'm killing a soul okay
oh there's more coming to me I actually needed that oh they don't have souls they're voids oh that's why they're like pitch black hello why am I still at the teacher's archive.
Wait, what happens now?
Oh, there is a dead guy.
Can it help?
Cannot.
My king, I'm sorry.
The sea calls.
What do I do?
What do I do from here?
Go down and to the right.
Oh, okay, I see it.
I see the light.
I go straight to the light follow the light follow the light oh it's like a little lighthouse yeah i see don't go to the light donkey turn crack all right go this way first because it's a wall climb
oh it was just the same way okay that way was just easier Hello.
I shall drink the dark liquid without questions asked.
Oh, shit.
Shade cloak.
Press RT to dash forward.
Use an attack without...
Oh!
It's like a roll.
Dash through enemies and attacks without taking damage.
Oh, okay.
It's like a...
I-frames, right?
I can I-frame it.
Oh my god, I can dash through everything now.
Oh!
Oh, and I get charmed.
Nice.
Yeah, I cannot dash through everything.
That's pretty good.
Alright, now we go home.
Oh wait, I can just...
I can just UFO.
You seem we have a problem.
Alright, nice.
It's a little cool down.
Oh, it does.
I see it.
Alright.
Now that we do that, can I do the third alien now?
This is in Queen's Garden?
Okay, now I can do the third alien.
Nice.
Oh my god, how do I get back up?
Oh, this is what the platform is for.
Now I know why they gave me so many platforms.
Oh, fuck yeah, I don't care that much.
Not slowly.
Wait, how the fuck...
Oh, I was gonna say it.
Where do I go now?
This way.
Oh, shit.
Are you serious?
The platform was below me!
Okay.
I'll just go this way.
Fuck this.
No!
Oh my god, please, please.
Oh my god, thank god, thank god.
Okay, I don't have to...
I don't have to do the...
The full clan.
Thank god.
Oh, thank god, okay.
Oh my god, I hate this.
Actually, I do go from here.
Okay.
This should be...
I can't do the left side yet apparently because I don't have the uh I don't have the spell for it
oh hey wait where did you come from did I go too far wait just in case just hello I see you face the place of your birth and now drape yourself in the substance of the shadow is born of similar size.
That part of you, that crucial emptiness, I do not share.
Hey, big sister!
Funny then that such darkness gives me hope.
Within it, I see the chance to change.
A difficult journey, you would face, but a choice it can create.
Prolong our world's stasis or face the heart of its infection.
I urge you to take the harder path, but what end may come, the decision rests with you.
Dream!
It faced the void and said, Escape.
Can you ignite such vast darkness?
Where am I?
Oh, that's...
Oh, she was meeting me here.
Yeah, I met myself.
All right, now back to Among Us.
All right.
I gotta go this way.
Okay.
Then we fly this way to the bench.
I had to be sure.
to be sure that like like she was telling me something important okay the abyss okay now we gotta go to we gotta go to the stack station and then go to queen station okay we gotta go this way
oh wait don't worry the filler episode will end very soon don't we're all done with the filler guys we're almost done with the filler part okay queen station
and I dream him I already dreamed this guy I try so easily now yeah I remember I dreamed him before I had to go to the mantis Lord why oh the deep nest i go to the deep nest by the mantis village and the fungal waste okay it's there and then there all right okay how do i get there okay to the fungal waste i go all right it's deep nest time
most people see deep nest and go nope oh my gosh i'm just gonna it's gonna be pain isn't it i'm gonna have a terrible time i can feel it i remember we we saw that and you guys were like stop turn back i remember we almost went to the deepness and all you guys were like turn back you're not supposed to be here it's not worth it
It is this way.
That place.
Okay, and then go this way.
Surely it can't be that bad, guys.
Haha!
And then this way.
And down I'll go into the hole.
And down I'll go to another hole.
A lot of backtracking.
The fact that they won't die for me is really fucked up.
What kind of cult do you have, Mantis Village?
Alright.
I'm at the deep nest now.
I got the map, though, for the deep nest for some fucking reason.
I'm like wondering, how do we get to that part?
Are you thinking here that I can?
Alright, this way.
Yay, I can watch them.
Just want to make sure there's no secret tunnel.
Secret tunnel.
I swear, everyone forgets Queen's Garden connects to Deep Nest 2.
Name is Super Chat Nicholas.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, I remember.
I...
I hear the tumbling.
The sound of the tumbles.
I remember.
What is this?
Oh, shit!
Okay, this went nowhere!
Oh, wait, no.
Okay, that was actual bait.
I thought there would be...
Okay, oh, it's just...
I mean, it's money, I guess.
Alright, it's money.
I mean, I'll take it.
Oh my god.
I don't like this area already.
This area does not bring me joy.
I don't think it ever gave anybody joy.
Okay.
What's on the left side?
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh, okay.
I couldn't tell what that does.
Oh, what the fuck?
Oh, it's a Trap!
Oh, what am I looking at?
What the fuck am I looking at?
I don't even know what I'm looking at.
Okay, that's just money.
We don't need money.
Okay, we can go up.
Assume we can go...
Oh my god, we can go up.
I just heal real quick.
okay obviously that was gonna break anyway
okay they're pretty weak so i don't have to i know i'm not that scared
we don't need money that badly guys not yet why are these guys dead okay now we go left jesus christ that alien is so far he's so fucking far
from me.
Where do I go?
Down or up?
I'll go down for now.
Yeah, I'll keep going down.
Oh!
I- I- Okay, that was scary.
But like, we're okay.
Oh!
Wait.
Can we not go that way?
Where do I go?
Oh my god.
Oh, and I can't kill him.
He's just so beefy.
Alright.
Is anything up here?
No?
Oh.
Still nothing?
Oh, this is a maze.
This maze fucking sucks.
Welcome to the deep nests, baby.
Where am I?
Oh, that's...
Okay, now I'm here.
Wait, there's bats there.
Okay, I figured it out.
Oh, my God.
I don't know how, but I figured it out.
Alright, let's look at this map.
Oh, okay.
We did it.
Why is there so many pitfalls?
We fucking did it.
I don't know how, but we figured it out.
That's America.
Wait, now where is this area taking me?
Oh my god, where am I going now?
It's just a break.
Or go, wait.
Where does left go?
The mask is all the way to the left.
Oh Right, it's just a charm Is the charm not good?
Do we not want the charm?
Oh shit!
Whoops.
No, it's a pain in the ass to get.
I just got money.
Wait, where do I go here?
Okay, clearly it's not there.
Where the fuck do I go?
Oh, here.
And then up?
Where am I?
Where the fuck this map isn't helping me?
Oh, my God.
Oh, no, not the spikes.
Oh.
I'm very confused oh my god wait is this oh no I know exactly what this is no I oh yeah I had a feeling this is some just basically like super Mario maker shit oh my god
Yeah, this shit is like Super Mario Shit, Super Mario Maker shit They always do this in Mario Maker Oh, I lost it Oh, I think I was so far Okay We got this Okay, I sort of I don't remember how to get back there Oh my god, I don't even know if we could Oh,
my, I'm thinking like Can I even get myself Can I even get my stuff back?
It's so fucked up.
Like where the area I lost it in.
It's pretty fucked up.
I guess it's so frustrating.
Yeah.
Maybe my soul would come visit me.
Oh thank god.
it to let make it easier okay we're just gonna wait just gonna wait for the next tram are
you serious oh that is bullshit that is bullshit that's actually
bullshit okay I hate this oh
my god I made it I actually made it holy fuck I made it just better give me something fucking good this art is just so it's just okay this
oh my god i have to go up oh my okay
okay okay we're up we're up we're up up up up we go
Oh my god, oh, it was a mask.
Hucking a demon K-pop on there right there.
Do not have the range to sing that.
We actually did it.
And all I got was a fucking mask.
The deadliest elevator of all time.
All I got was a dumb mask.
Alright.
And then, so how do we get the charge?
Where is the charm?
It's down, like here?
Oh, it's down there.
Here.
Wait, no.
This is where I started.
How the fuck did I get there?
Bottom, right?
Oh, here.
Oh, my God.
There was a hole there.
I didn't even see the hole.
Which hole do I go?
okay oh i don't like this oh i don't like that oh i don't oh i have to dash oh oh okay okay i get it
all right i get it i get this shit is stupid but i get it
okay that's that's dumb i don't know if i have enough h oh i get it i got it thanks oh i got another charm wait how many charms do i have should i have enough i should have i should be close
right i thought there would be money there
all right we got another oh whoa Garpid.
Dream!
Oh, never mind.
No dreaming for you.
I guess.
No, you don't got the dream because you have no soul, I guess.
You didn't go to heaven.
So you don't get the dream.
I'm dead.
What were your thoughts when he did that?
I don't know.
I just, I dashed.
I thought that was a good dash.
At least I can get healed.
Alright, I triple heal.
That means I can triple live now.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, 11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16, 17, 18, 19, 20.
Alright.
We need 5 more to unlock another charm slot.
Oh, Spring gives full juice?
Oh yeah, I should give full juice.
Oh, I thought you meant, like, Solus, but just the HP.
These guys are little babies.
I can kill them.
Alright, I don't want to worry too much about these guys.
Pretty weak.
Oh, it does.
Alright, it doesn't really matter.
I'm very strong as fuck.
What?
What's that sound?
It's like, oh.
Wait, something's chasing me.
Something's trying to fucking chase me right now.
It was like scurrying and everything.
Oh, that's fine.
I can heal from this.
Yeah, I heard you was like, who's chasing me?
Oh, hey, he got captured again.
I thought he was a great mighty.
Whatever his name was.
I already forgot his name.
How do I save him?
Oh, my God.
That poor guy's washed.
Hate to break it to you, but you might be washed, old man.
Don't save him.
Wait, what?
What did he do?
don't save him
people just hate him I
mean I could just leave him right now
you hear that
I don't even know how to get to this guy yeah guys what happened to like So now you're saying not all bugs lives matter, huh?
Wow!
A bunch of hypocrites, guys!
Now all bugs don't matter!
Hmm!
Oh, is this...
Wait, what?
Is there...
How do I get there?
I don't even think I can save him.
I don't even know how to get there.
Yeah, nothing... none of the rocks break.
Oh, there it is!
I was like, Jesus, what the fuck is the...
Oh, up more?
Where?
He's beyond saving.
Another room?
Oh, did I have to go here?
from another entrance okay I'll just go this way then oh there's a bench here I'll find this bench first bench important bench equals HP wait we're bench we're bench oh they're bench yeah all right let's see what was it you guys were saying was over which one was the one that I just got was this?
Sharp shadow?
I don't even remember.
Whatever.
I don't have space anyway.
Get tram pass first.
How do I get that?
Here?
Oh, that's...
God.
It looks scary.
Is there anything else here that I have to go?
Left?
Okay, we'll go left.
Okay.
All right.
Oh my god, it spit out a child.
All right, that's gross.
Bro, that's disgusting.
Go to the hospital for that.
I did not consent to see you do that.
I did not consent to see you give birth.
All right.
Left dot go.
Left, oh, extra HP.
Butterfly is HP.
Yay.
What's here?
Oh, is this the tram?
Oh, it's the old tram system.
Okay, here I go.
Stop getting pregnant.
Open that.
Look at this open.
Oh, it gave me a shortcut.
Okay.
I'm not here to see.
The miracle of childbirth is very disgusting.
Yeah.
Oh my god, there's more.
Oh my god.
He like spit his child on me.
He like threw his child on my body.
That's fucking gross.
Alright, I got the tram pass.
Okay, now do I just go all the way back, right?
I know he just threw his child.
He didn't want to take care of it anymore.
Yeah.
Let's go this way.
Yay!
Okay, uh...
We will go...
We go this way now.
Whoa, where am I?
Oh, shit.
Ow!
dude god i hate this area i'm just so confused like i know i'm always confused but like i'm so confused this area is like makes me even more confused than normal
oh it's like it's like a clicker situation it inhabits their bodies after i kill them
Of course he spits up.
Oh my god, of course.
Gets like a little ledge here.
Is this where he lives?
Okay, no, not here.
Oh, right here.
Is this where Zot is?
Zot?
Are you here?
Oh, there he is.
You're gonna go.
Oh, they're all like spotted.
Oh my, I just noticed that there's spiders.
Because we haven't seen, like, an actual spider bug yet that we've killed.
So I'm pretty sure the next boss is a fucking spider boss, isn't it?
It's a spider boss.
I can feel it.
Yeah, they're little spiders.
Where the fuck is the Zode passageway?
I guess that's a spider, but, like...
Oh, okay.
I just realized this guy's also a spider Because he has eight legs, I think But we haven't seen like a spider boss yet
Okay, oh Wait, I'm back here What the fuck?
I'm back here Wait, I just I went in the circle I Alright, let me sit on the bench I literally went in the circle I thought I was making progress I was like, look at all that progress I made, guys!
Wow!
I made so much progress, everyone.
Oh, I hear him crawling.
There he is.
Okay, I just gotta go left this time.
Oh, I thought it was this way.
How the fuck did this guy die?
How do I...
Oh my gosh, I'm so confused.
Okay, we gotta go up.
And then left.
This time.
Okay, this time we go left instead.
And then...
Yeah, we go full left.
Ow.
There we go, full left this time.
Oh, I don't like the sound they make when they're crotlit, when they're running away.
Oh, shit.
What the fuck?
Oh, my God.
I was not ready for that.
He literally just randomly showed up in my game.
What the fuck?
You win.
I'll come back later.
You can stay there.
I'll come back.
Let me just farm some HP.
Okay, I shadow...
Oh, I can shadow dash.
I forgot.
I forgot about my shadow dash.
I'm using like...
Like...
Okay, never mind.
He's dead anyway.
Okay.
That works anyway.
Whatever.
It still works.
Oh, is that a hidden area?
Oh, it is.
Oh, I didn't have to fight him.
Okay, now they're all just spiders.
Okay, now this is just spiders.
The boss has to be a giant fucking spider.
I could feel it.
I could feel the spider boss.
Wait, there's a grub above me.
How do I get above there?
Oh, I don't think I can yet.
Unless here?
Oh, I'm here.
What?
Oh, it's because I dashed already.
Oh, okay.
I was like, wait, why can't I do it?
Why can't I dash him?
Oh, this guy is annoying.
I'm going to try the dash thing again.
Yeah, never mind.
I don't have enough range.
What the fuck?
Okay, let's get it.
Oh, of course.
Of course that hits me.
Yeah, it doesn't work, guys.
Who told me to do the shadow step?
You lied.
It didn't work.
Oh.
Wait, he's fucking chipped.
Are you serious?
He does three.
He does three slant.
Okay, we're leaving.
You can have that area.
We're leaving.
You win.
you win I'm not Oh my god I actually could have died there I actually almost died
What the fuck
Okay that was That was bullshit
Oh my god The one life and a dream right now The one Live in the dream.
The deep nest, baby.
Oops, saw spikes.
Oh my god.
He wins.
Okay, I got the grub.
Goodness.
Oh, yeah, I have a feeling I need the...
What is it?
The shadow charm that makes me dash further.
Because I don't think I can do a dash with my current setup.
Like to dash past him.
Unless I'm like, I space it out correctly.
But even then I feel like it's so hard to space it out.
He just wins.
Like he's just better than me.
Are you serious?
I'm like.
God, I'm trying to figure out how to kill this guy.
Oh.
Oh, thank you for this, Solus.
Thank you for the HP.
Oh, that looks like a spot.
Oh!
I hate this area.
I hate this area so much.
Okay.
Up?
Wait, what?
where's the it points up or is it down bench to the right that's a hole
what I got a platform like these platforms oh okay I was like where the fuck is my where is it like I got cheated out of my stag.
Yeah?
Okay, I feel like the ball of yarn is the boss fight.
Oh, there it is.
Oh, goodbye, bench.
Oh, they broke my bench.
Guess I don't get the fucking rest.
But just in case, I'm gonna go to the stag, beater.
I...
I don't know.
I'll just get to resting ground.
Bench in the house?
Okay.
Just in case I get one guide.
I'm going to go to the bench in this random area.
And then.
I'll go to the back.
Just in case.
I have trust issues now.
Can't believe they would break my bench like that.
What the fuck?
The government paid for my bench.
my tax pay my tax paying dollars pay for this bench how dare you hello oh hey there is a bench yay oh oh that was the trap oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh wait sir sir
oh did you say trusted all right now you see why i have trusted shoes didn't even question okay now you guys know why i have trusted shoes yeah another reason to never trust nobody i hate these guys so much these guys are i don't i don't care
Oh, Nassia.
To be fair, we didn't lie.
There was a bench in there.
Thank you for the super chat, Liam.
Thank you, thank you.
To be fair, there was a bench, Mr. Muffluckins.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I knew it.
Another reason.
The fact that it says double hit, fucking sucks.
Knock knock.
Oh, shit!
Oh, nice.
Knock knock.
Good distance.
I don't want to waste my healing.
spell on him.
Because he does, the thing is, he does double damage, and I'm getting so scared.
Oh my gosh, where does this go?
Wait, where does this go?
Oh, is this just a shortcut?
Oh, it's a shortcut.
Oh, I like that.
That statue looks scary.
Eh.
I hear a heartbeat.
whose heartbeat is that oh my god not you again knock knock I'm gonna do this now wait what it hurt me wait what hurt me yeah like what hurt me there
oh it reached me I didn't even realize he oh my god this goddamn fucking range I didn't even notice that that reached me.
Okay.
So one more here.
I don't trust going down.
I feel like down is just like...
It opens like either spikes or a shortcut.
Here?
That is...
That's either a grub or like those little wing things.
That seems like a trap grub.
Oh my god, he was a...
real grub thought it was a trap it was just so easy the fact that he was just there with nothing to guard him
okay oh my god are you serious look at this guy okay nice oh I actually have to like shoot me left and right.
Can I go this way?
No!
Oh no.
I'm not using
magic here.
I need to heal.
Jesus Christ, he takes fucking forever.
Back up.
Fuck it.
I'm gonna use that.
I gave up.
This took too long.
Oh, now I'm here.
Oh, there he is.
Oh, I made it!
Dream!
Oh, I should have talked to him first.
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to talk to him.
I just went straight for murder.
Bound for brood for child.
fair bargain made give all for her for her for her all right I'll give her the London special here we go
yay oh focus time get inside okay Oh my god, actual progress.
Now we're making actual progress.
Oh, that's Hornet's mom?
Damn.
She's sick.
Compared to her.
Oh, I should have...
If you told me earlier, I would have been Jane Silksong.
Could have been Jane Silksong there.
I could have stabbed my mom.
And that you have one boss left, the final one.
In the temple of the black egg.
Liam, they give us Super Chat.
Oh, hi.
It's not about your mom.
So you slain the beast and you head towards that faded goal.
And now I've obstructed this happening, but it caused me some pain to knowingly stand idle.
What?
You might think me stern, but I'm not completely cold.
We do not choose our mothers or their circumstance into which we are born.
Despite all the ills of this world, I am thankful for the life she granted me.
Only allowing her to pass And taking the burden of the future and her said Can I begin to repay this?
Alright, what do you, how do you feel?
Mother, I give mine action.
But another path may be possible.
Alright, guys.
Here's, alright, here are...
Okay.
Technically, we can get the first ending now.
And then we'll do the true ending Next week.
Before Silk's on.
Guys, I can do one more part.
And we can try and gather all the true ending stuff.
Or...
Actually, wait, do you think I get true ending?
I can get the true ending uh uh next in one try in one playthrough or get the first ending now
go for it now no?
Alright, let's go fight the let's go get the first ending then alright, then we'll get the first ending oh fuck, there's of course there's Spice, hello
Hello.
Alright.
Then we'll get the first ending.
And then we'll do the...
Sorry, I made a little oopsie there.
You didn't see that.
Jane.
I don't even know how to get back.
I'm just like...
How do I get back?
Wait.
Aren't I trapped in...
Oh, left was the way out.
I was like, oh, wait a minute.
How do I get out of here?
Jamie, David, yeah, I'm sorry I killed your mom, but like, how do I leave this place?
She never told me how to leave.
Okay.
It's on the left side, this side.
I just realized, yeah, I was like, wait a minute, how do I get out of here?
Oh, here's the bench.
Nice.
Alright.
Now I go down.
Did I get out?
Oh, shit.
They all died.
Wait, what happened to them?
They're all gone.
Oh my god, and the bench is gone, too.
Alright, let's get the first ending.
Okay.
They weren't real.
It was just all in my head.
I fucking knew you.
I thank God I went to that bench.
Thank God I went to a random bench here.
But...
Wait, Zoet died?
Wait, we killed him?
No, it's okay.
It'll be fine, right?
I said I'll BRB.
Wait, no, we don't know that.
Guys, we don't know that.
Maybe he married a lovely spider lady.
Maybe...
It'll be fine.
Don't worry guys.
He'll be fine.
We don't know.
We never came back for him, but But he's fine.
He'll be I bet you he's like he's okay
You don't know that maybe he met a lovely spider lady It'll be fine
Doki stop coping he'll be okay.
Okay, we gotta figure out okay it has to be like the it's like what this one right the big black thing in the middle that looks that really does look like final boss thing like oh so went to go visit the farm yeah he just went to the farm of stay it should be fine we don't need gathering swarm we don't need compass.
You don't need that.
Okay, what should our, should we get shot?
Okay, we need, should we get the, oh, we can't do soul eater.
We can get rid of set, do we need steady body?
We can get steady body and grab soul eater and then have like a magic build too.
Quick slash?
Is steady body that important?
Oh, helps me stay alive?
Okay.
All right, if we do that, we gotta figure out nail we'll get long nail maybe and then long i don't think i can get quick i i can't afford quick slash so i'll grab i'll grab the thorn just in case we'll do this all right all right we'll rest yeah i got range i think i got range yeah i got long nail
Yeah.
Gotta make sure I got everything.
Wait.
Oh, okay.
Mark of pride.
Wait, do I get mark of pride or...
Oh, it's a better one.
Oh, okay.
I wasn't sure.
I didn't realize that, too.
They were both...
They both looked like...
I thought it was just one charm.
Okay, I'll get that then.
Alright.
Oh, they also stab it.
Doesn't matter.
I can only get...
one anyway.
Ooh, that is long range.
Yeah, but I can't afford to.
Alright, we'll do the, we'll get the first ending.
Hello!
I'm here to kill you, I guess.
Just like how I killed the others.
Well, I'm here to give you a good old welcome to London.
There's a bench here?
Where's the bench?
Oh, that'll just go inside.
What's the worst that could happen?
I don't think I can first try a final boss, guys.
We'll see how long this will take me.
Oh.
Yeah, no, I'm not first trying this.
Is that my bench?
Oh, that's my bench.
Is any rock a bench now?
My god.
I have loads.
Of those standards, that does not look like a bench.
Oh, break this, I guess.
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
So I hear you're the Hollow Knight.
If I kill you, I become the Hollow Knight.
Hello, sir.
Hello?
That's...
John Hollow Knight?
Why is he so tall?
It's not fair.
Oh, shit.
My timing is fucked right now.
Wait, can I heal from here?
Hey.
He's like, no!
That's fucked.
Okay, I can heal, though.
Oh, what?
What?
What the fuck was that?
Okay.
I don't like that move.
Yeah, I think he...
I definitely can't first try this.
Yeah, this... That move...
That explosion fucked me over.
How's that...
Okay.
I don't know how to deal.
Do I just dash into him?
I didn't see the explosion from...
It went by so fast, I didn't see the explosion.
Oh my god.
What the fuck?
How did I not hit that?
Okay.
I hate...
Oh my god.
Nice.
I can heal.
I can grab two heals too.
Do I dash into that when he...
Oh my god.
He TP's when I was supposed to...
I was trying to pogo him.
Oh my god.
I wanted to pogo him.
That was bullshit.
A fucking course.
Oh, I see it now.
I see it.
That's...
thing fucks with me oh I understand it but like it's the explosion it's the explosion I like when he screams I'm like okay oh all right okay oh Fucking course, you dash again.
Oh.
Okay.
There you go.
At least I can heal.
Okay, I see it.
I have to be, like, on the ground when he does that.
I need to remember to be on the ground.
Okay.
Okay, nice.
Nice, I can heal.
Okay.
Oh, that was literally on me.
I...
That's unlucky.
He was literally on me when that happened.
Okay, nice.
Oh, new move.
New move.
Can I heal when he does that?
Nice.
I don't know what he did.
I...
Oh, I don't like this!
I don't like this move!
I don't like it!
Oh, it's so oh!
It's so, I'm so bad!
Not Toho!
I don't know what to do with you Toho!
Oh god, not Toho.
Okay.
Oh god.
No!
No you don't understand!
Toho fucks would be so much!
Oh my god.
I'm so bad when it comes to Toho.
Okay.
Oh god.
Okay, I can heal.
Okay, that should not have hit me.
Yay!
Oh, I did it!
Woo!
Free chat!
That's a cure!
Am I not and stride you but i did it sussy okay get in my body too
get inside i shall be john hollow knight i
i shall become john hollow light the among us buff is insane
Congrats on the bad ending.
It's so dramatic.
It said, I remembered among us.
Mary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yay!
I did it.
I saved everyone.
Uh, wait, I am John.
Oh my god, Piccadino Vessa!
Crokey would have finished it fast.
Oh, thanks.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Yeah, I'm John Hollow Knight now.
It's a second.
Okay, it's the second worst ending.
That's not the worst ending, guys.
It's only the second worst ending.
Not the worst ending.
It's not last.
Gabriel, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You just doomed Hollow Knight.
congrats yeah but now but i became john hollow knight sacrifices had to be made okay i wanted to be the main character on the cover of the game sacrifices have to be made it's me or hollow nest and i picked me that's fun we're gonna don't worry this is not the last part played This is not the last part for Hollow Knight.
I will do another part before Silk Song.
And then we'll see if I don't know if we can get...
I don't know.
I'm not sure if we will be able to do everything for the true end.
But we'll do our best.
We're going to do our best to do everything for the true ending of Hollow Knight.
Before Silk Song.
Yeah.
Like next week.
And after then we're going to do it again.
that true ending is a lot of stuff that's why i'm saying we'll try
we'll try and then we'll go into silk sock yeah it's doable in one stream patrick we saved all of this meanwhile outside why the heck is their orange group thing still around refugio thank you the super chat thank you thank you go to him among us died for our sins thank you the super chat Thank you.
Thank you.
Now do 112% Meep, thank you for the Magenta Super.
Holy fuck.
What, okay, that is a little crazy though.
That might be a little crazy.
But I had a great time.
I can't believe we were able to beat Hollow Knight.
I don't know.
I'm not sure if we could do 112% But I'll do my best to do the true ending.
Because everyone is saying that the true ending leads to Silk Song, right?
True ending is where Silk Song follows up with, right guys?
Is that right?
My way, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what my Halloween plans are yet.
Well done.
Achieving this great feat.
You persevered and triumphed.
Yay, I did it.
don't know yet no one actually knows okay then we'll just we'll just try it we'll try our best to get the true ending um 58 yeah guys i think we're a bit far off from 112 percent we're a bit we're oh it did in 12 hours wait that's pretty good i heard like an average playthrough was like what 27 hours to get to the end i mean i feel like that's pretty good for 12 yeah guys we're a little bit far off from 112 percent like Yeah,
just a little bit, yeah Yeah Yeah,
no shade, no reviving Deficit, yeah, we're not doing that Uh, hi, thank you, Mr. Richard, thank you, thank you That was fun though, thank you guys Um, I'm happy we were able to Complete, we completed three parts Um, which was a lot faster, I feel I feel like that's a lot faster than I expected.
I thought we had to play more next week to actually get to the original, like, the first ending.
So I'm really happy that we were able to complete so much within three playthroughs.
And even then, the first playthrough was super short, too.
I think, like, I think I could have done it in two parts.
I definitely could have done it in two parts if the first stream wasn't so short.
And I enjoyed, like, I could have enjoyed instead all the way.
But it was definitely very addicting.
I can see why Hell in a Night was so hyped.
and because I played it just before silk song releases I didn't have to wait seven years
yay I get my sequel right after I finish holiday night yippee wow you cheater good for you
experience the sequel without having to wait seven years!
Yay!
So, had a great time.
I didn't understand the hype back then.
Now I now I do.
What?
That lucky you.
So, yeah, at first I didn't really understand the hype, but now, after playing Hollow Knight, I'm like, oh, wait, this is actually really, really fun.
to try out the sequel for it too so i'm really glad to be able to experience it soon in the next week uh but thank you all for watching guys i had a great time playing um playing holiday for you guys but next week we'll try and get the true ending next week before silk song um so it'll be another long stream and that means okay i'm trying to decide which what other skin to use um but um there is this there is one more skin i really want to use so i'm glad we're doing another part.
I think that's my favorite thing about doing like, you know, doing like different parts.
Do not use...
You don't even know which one I'm gonna use!
You guys don't even know which one I'm gonna use.
It couldn't be any of anything.
It could be anything.
Um, so I'm super excited.
That's like what the one thing that's like making me really excited about um each part is that um i i'm like picking what skin to put on uh for each part so it's been a ride i hope you like that i ended holla night with among us sorry because of course i i ended i ended holla night with an among us skin uh we do have bikini night skin wings thank you the super chat thank you thank you um other than silk song is there any other I think in the super chat,
thank you, thank you.
I think six souls.
I've seen a lot of six souls.
Is that what's called?
The one where you play a little like wolf thing?
That looked really, really.
That looked really, I really liked the art style of that game.
And the sus night.
All right, nine souls.
Sorry.
It's what happened to the three other numbers.
Sorry, I meant nine souls.
I lost count, okay.
Numbers are hard.
uh yeah what happened to the others i misplaced them um um but oh yeah i meant the prequel the six souls is the prequel guys uh but i i've wanted to try out nine souls before uh but i know that it's like also a very long game too so um that's why i haven't started it yet uh because like i said um you know the the series is just they make a lot of metrovanians are just incredibly long because that's what metro manias are and i've been really lost the entire time too uh but i had a lot of fun in in the end um there's something else i didn't talk about but i forgot i forgot already uh but anyway guys i hope you guys had a lot of fun watching for the first ending like i said next week i will try and get the true ending next week um i'll make an attempt to do a true ending and um and then we're we have silk song as well next week's schedule there's only one collab next week and there's two sponsors as well we have two sponsors next week a collab with uh tension the finished gears of war all
night silk song and then i don't know if i can i'm gonna i'm gonna try and get sleeping dogs in there it's a very packed schedule but i'll try my best any guys as always everybody stay hydrated posture check get them around to get that blood flowing and I'll see you guys next time,
everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.